going out to virginia we're gonna have a
conversation with aaron aaron how can
dr d and i help man hi
uh hi hi john and hi anthony big fans of
both y'all thanks so much for taking my
call
i appreciate you for calling in helping
me
all right so i i think i have a
two-pronged
question to uh to preface and to put it
shortly i think
my mom might be addicted to being
scammed or catfished and so
to to to summarize catfist yeah
okay i don't think what you said is a
thing but go ahead
catfish
i can't wait to hear this yeah okay all
right so
uh both of my parents are in their late
60s um
the they are likely going to be divorced
they've been separated for about six
months
um a few years ago they have been
um my mom has begun a series of
online dating emotionally and
financially
um in you know a series of online
relationships that have
that have been both emotionally and
financially
um infidelity that's a word not really
but we'll let it ride that sounds good
infidelity
thank you yes yeah right appreciate it
so
so she's been doing this kind of thing
for a while she's been paying
thousands and thousands of dollars to
people that don't exist
and not get gotten a dime of it back um
so anyway they've been separated for a
while and
so i recently became privy to her being
a part of
a whole new one and so i
let everybody around our family know all
of her
all of her friends who she's going to
ask for for money before
and i um so my my brother
and his fiance as well as myself we
intervened with her
yesterday pointed out that this
financial transaction that she was given
that was
looking to exchange thousands of stock
hey aaron hold on a minute i i like the
way this is going we gotta hear this one
yeah we're going to finish this
conversation
so hold on we're going to come back to
you after the break i mean because we
we're talking about being catfished
we're talking about she's fidelity
thousands of dollars
oh we're going to have us a good cause
infidelity
i'm going to look this is going to be
good yeah we'll be right back we're
going to go
back out to uh virginia and have a
conversation with aaron
and before we got off uh before the
break in it aaron correct me if i'm
wrong from what i understand is your mom
is about to have a divorce
um and she has been doing some online uh
dating situations and unfortunately your
mom has been
a catfish as far as and maybe being
misled
scammed to give other men other people
money
is that correct thus far yeah yep yep
that's cool 100 correct so what what's
your question for us today because i i i
man i just i'm loving this this one
right now what's your question
how can we help okay so
so the current situation and this will
lead to my question
we we intervened with her last night and
basically pointed out
um inconsistencies in a phony you know
transaction document
and she seemed to agree with what we
were saying
and and said that you know we what
you're putting your family's
identities at risk and and we can't be
we we can't be allowing you to make
these kinds of
behaviors anymore and she she acted
like she understands but um just today
she had indicated that
um she believes that it's a completely
valid transaction
and so what what i'd like to find out is
one um is there anything
that that that me or my family can do
to to be able to to protect her
because i feel like like like to her
this is like
professional wrestling but in
relationship format and she's a
seven-year-old boy
a part of her knows that it's not real
but she won't
um she she just doesn't really care
because she she's dirt broke and um
doesn't want to work
and is nearing you know she's getting
older and i feel like she's
she all of these scams have involved hey
send us five grand and then we'll give
you 100 gold bars and
stuff like that yeah so this hurts
and um i'm gonna say something that you
probably already know
um but your mom's an adult and
uh there's no there's no
laws against painfully hurtful
stupid decisions and um
you can protect yourself if you do think
you've got some back channels to find
out where
a particular scam is coming you can call
the police and ask them to look into it
um but at the end of the day what you
need to do is protect you and your
family
and um i i wish i had some better advice
for you i wish i had some better like
yeah you only do this this and this the
reality is
you're 65 year old mom your six-year-old
mom
um is struggling from some connection
issues and it sounds like she's in a
marriage that um this is
is over at some shape form or fashion
she's been seeking connection
online and there is something about a
dopamine hit there's
some oxytocin hits that you get when you
give somebody money it feels good for a
second and then you get onto the next
thing and that's what predators do
especially online predators but but
here's the thing dr d
and and i think this is where and
correct me if i'm wrong because i could
be wrong
you know you are never wrong uh but i
have a problem trying to protect
a grown woman and i'm being stressed and
i'm
and i'm trying to help i need to be
protecting and providing for my family
let's just say like
you've got to make sure that your social
security number your checking accounts
make sure that people in her world
don't give her money yes um yeah and
yeah you do all your due diligence
you're exactly right yeah but at the end
of the day
all you can protect is you and that's
heartbreaking um i think
having a group of people who love her to
rally around and have a hard
conversation that's good
yeah man i hope she can hear it um
doesn't sound like she's able to yeah
and that's my thing once i sit down and
i have a conversation with my mother if
she was getting catfishing she was still
giving away money
that's my mom that's my mom that's my
mom i mean that's i'm gonna be hurt i'm
gonna be upset but i can't stress over
my mother's life
when i have i'm dealing with a lot of
stuff right you know so i'm not worried
about that but man i hate that for you
and your family guys i hate that for you
and your family
yeah yeah yeah keep having a hard
conversation uh but
also keep loving your mom